und wer weiter nämlich dieses gespräch
noch mal um unseren bild meinung chef
philippe piatti bei uns im studio ist ja
philipp das ganze wurde er insgesamt
komplett chaotisch auch vorbereitet ich
meinen allein diese geschichte die
hannes gerade erzählt hat eine wirkliche
alte dame die da fasst er friert in der
schlange wie kann so etwas passieren
ja das ist wirklich wahnsinn was haben
es hier uns gerade erzählt hat
eigentlich wenn man lange im schlangen
sieht könnte man ja meinen wie toll das
sind bilder der hoffnung da machen sich
menschen auf um sich impfen zu lassen
also genau das wofür wir alle trommeln
wissenschaftler politiker medien aber
dann muss man sich eigentlich vorstellen
warum sind wir darauf eigentlich nicht
vorbereitet warum müssen menschen gerade
stundenlang in der kälte stehen um sich
impfen zu lassen ich meine man weiß doch
angeblich seit august davon dass
irgendwann die booster kampagne starten
soll am vergangenen donnerstag beim
großen corona gipfel haben bund und
länder ja zur nationalen
kraftanstrengung ausgerufen aber wir
sind davon überhaupt nicht dafür
überhaupt nicht vorbereitet die
impfzentren wurden dicht gemacht und
werden jetzt langsam wieder hochgefahren
jens spahn hat den impfstoff rationiert
zumindest in bayern tag impfstoff den
die ganzen leute wollten das ist der
beliebteste impfstoff und dazu kommt es
wurde plötzlich zum boostern für alle
aufgerufen anstatt erst mal die zu
ostern die es ganz ganz dringend
brauchen nämlich die senioren und die
sehen jetzt ganz besonders alters die
müssen nämlich wirklich in der kälte
stehen was sie natürlich am wenigsten ab
können und wer kann aber lange in der
schlange stehen die jüngeren die den
impfstoff aber gar nicht so dringend
brauchen wir die alten und gleichzeitig
wird zur impfpflicht bzw wird über die
impfpflicht schon diskutiert kann das
denn überhaupt funktionieren falls es
jetzt eine impfpflicht geben würde wenn
es jetzt schon so lange schlangen gibt
also man stelle sich vor dass nicht nur
die impfwilligen gerade anstehen würden
sondern alle menschen die tatsächlich
jetzt auch müssten dann würden wir das
noch weniger hinbekommen und das zeigt
auch glaube ich den ganzen charakter
dieser impfpflicht debatte ganz egal wie
man dazu steht zu einer allgemeinen
pflicht aber die impfpflicht debatte ist
gerade eine politische nebelkerze ein
ablenkungsmanöver um davon abzulenken
dass die politik sich nicht vorbereitet
hat dass sie das land nicht auf die
booster kampagne vorbereitet hat sowie
andere länder ist getan haben wir können
so mal bilder von gestern aus hamburg
auch anschauen da stehen hunderte
menschen die sich impfen lassen wollen
aber viel viel zeit mitbringen müssen
vor der elbphilharmonie die philharmonie
selbst hat dieses video er gestern
getwittert man sieht da diese nicht
enden wollende schlange die über die
brücke geht hin bis zur philharmonie um
sich dort den zweiten oder dritten peaks
abzuholen wie kann die situation
verbessert werden insbesondere für die
senioren ja also ich glaube man kriegt
das auf die schnelle nicht hin glaube so
einfach ist es zu sagen man kriegt es
auf die schnelle nicht hin alle sofort
ohne diese warterei zu boostern und du
hast ja vorhin gefragt wie viele
menschen sind es die sich pusten lassen
wollen wie viele sind dass sie die
erstimpfung abholen in den vergangenen
tagen waren über 70 prozent der menschen
die eine impfung bekommen haben das
waren alles booster patienten was kann
man aber ganz schnell tun die
kassenärzte haben heute alarm geschlagen
haben einen brandbrief an ihren sparen
geschrieben das hat mein kollege julius
böhm enthüllt und haben gesagt wir
müssen wieder priorisieren so wie wir
das von anfang der impfkampagne kannten
das heißt zuerst die älteren erst 80 70
60 usw nur so kann man gewährleisten
dass die menschen die den booster schott
am dringendsten brauchen ihn auch
bekommen gab es da schon reaktionen aus
der politik hast du da schon was gehört
also ich kann sagen das gibt gerade
viele interne runden in denen beraten
wird es gibt gab heute mittag eine
schaltkonferenz zwischen kanzleramtschef
helge braun und den bundesländern mann
ist massiv unzufrieden mit der
kommunikation von jens spahn aber auch
mit der politischen entscheidung die
impfzentren dich zum rachen man sieht
das als massiven fehler an und sucht
jetzt nach möglichkeiten also zum
beispiel versucht denkt man darüber nach
wie man ganz schnell die apotheker mit
einbeziehen könnte und aber ehrlich
gesagt man kommt an der priorisierung
kaum vorbei weil man hat jetzt völlig
überhastet auch vielleicht ohne die ganz
große not alle zum boosten aufgerufen
und das bringt gerade diejenigen in die
bredouille die das amt rings brauchen
die senioren die müssen jetzt in der
kälte warten und die intensionen
schlechtesten waren philipp etter vielen
dank dafür philipp